All right.
You're done.
Let's look at my solution.
First, I hope you grabbed
the projection from the notes.
Since we're populating a list view,
we need a weather entry ID, but
since we have a join,
we have to specify this ID precisely
with a table name followed by the dot
followed by the column name syntax.
We're not using all of these columns.
But, having these constant defined
will help us keep the code
compatible with the updates we
are doing in the next lessons.
Of course, these indices
are tied to our projection.
If the forecast columns changes,
we have to modify these accordingly.
In onCreateLoader we then pass
FORECAST_COLUMNS as the projection
into our CursorLoader constructor.
Finally, we can fix
a convertCursorRowToUSFormat within our
forecast adapter to take advantage
of these declared indices.
And that's it, we're done.
let's run it.
And it looks exactly like
the last time we run it.
[LAUGH] Is pretty typical for
this section.
But the good news is that
it's still working correctly.
And, it's a little more efficient.
We're going to take more
advantage of this in lesson five
as we make more sophisticated
user interfaces.